Prior to the development of drugs for mental illness, people with mental
disorders, as we mentioned in the last lesson, were often treated poorly. There
were not effective behavioral therapies, or psychotherapy developed, to help
individuals manage their symptoms. And therefore, many people resided in mental
institutions or state hospitals. In fact, by 1955 there were over half of a
million of a people of the United States who were living in mental
institutions. Then came the discovery of the phenothiazines. These were
initially developed as antihistamines, and they were first studied for their
mildly sedating action. Chlorpromazine, that goes by the trade name Thorazine
was the second phenotiazine discovered and it was found produced calmness,
conscious sedation, disinterest in and detachment from external stimuli. This
condition was termed a Neuroleptic state and chlorpromazine was the first
antipsychotic or neuroleptic drug. And these are used to manage psychosis.
Neuroleptic drugs are strong tranquilizers that are perscribed for
Schizophrenia. These drugs are effective for treating the symptoms of
Schizophrenia because they decrease delusions and hallucinations. In fact,
these were so effective, that by 1993, fewer than 220,000 people were still
residing in mental institutions. The dramatic decrease in those living in
institutions was due to the development of drug therapy. These individuals were
now able to manage their symptoms and they could leave the hospital and live
with family members or in group homes.